what kind of gabble is
thator I don't have I don't own a gabble
anymore
good morning everyone I now call to the
order the uh commission to study the
purpose of proposing legislation for a
stake control sales of cannabis and
cannabis
products
Senator Lang would you wish to lead us
in the pledge
sure
do we I believe we need to start by
adopting the minutes Mr chair I move we
adopt the minutes as written and
presented excuse me m Mr chair I did
have one question on on the minutes if I
may you recogniz the last bullet uh talk
about HB 1598 the majority of the
committee members want to pick apart HB
1598 and most likely merge it with the
franchise model um I don't recall the
commission taking a vote on this so I'm
wondering how we arrived at that
majority sure as reading as writing
those minutes I took it as the people
people speaking in favor of of that
proposal versus the ones that didn't
speak at all or spoke against so it was
just a a d derivation of the
conversation okay uh shall we amend
these
minutes I I believe the the and I'm
going off of memory here but my
understanding was by using 1598 as a a
model we just I think we need a a floor
where we start and if we're going to do
anything just having something in front
of us nothing whatever we start with any
bill that we use as kind of like a
beginning point is not even remotely
close to what the final product would be
if we even get to that point my whole
point is we just want to have something
as a kind of a reference point and I
think using what the same bill would
make it easier for everyone to follow
along with including members of the
public uh Mr chair I have a
comment if if if the issue is just the
word majority let's just delete the word
okay already crossed that one on my
notes you can just say uh you can just
say the committee members
discussed you know the committee
members
discussed using HB
1598 and merging it with the franchise
model with with that with those minor
changes yes thank you is there any other
objection to the minutes being
adopted all in favor please say I
I those
opposed I'd like to abstain I wasn't
here four we had two uh we have on the
agenda we have uh people speaking uh
from DH
chess Trisha
here good morning chair good morning
committee um my name is Patricia Tilly I
am the director of Public Health for the
New Hampshire Department of Health and
Human Services and my name is Michael
Holt I'm the administrator of the
therapeutic cannabis program thank you
just before we begin are we live
streaming can someone answer
that anyone know anyone know if we're
live streaming right
now one
second and if we're not live streaming
is there a way that we can live
stream
yes it's live right there we're we're
live all right we're live streaming
everyone so we good sorry about that
thank you sure so thank you very much um
so today we're going to talk a little
bit about the therapeutic cannabis
program and the ways in which it can
align and certain opportunities that we
might have with the conversations that
you're having now about an adult use
recreational Market um Mike is the
foremost expert in therapeutic cannabis
uh in New Hampshire he so he is going to
be taking the bulk of our presentation
um I'm just here for color commentary
and I will let you start off
Mike thank you
Trisha uh thanks for having us today um
New Hampshire's therapeutic cannabis
program is a legislatively mandated
program that provides critical services
to a segment of the New Hampshire
population that is geographically
diverse and spans all age groups and
socioeconomic backgrounds from children
living with cancer to Veterans with PTSD
to the to the elderly with chronic pain
the program has been serving patients
since
2016 the patients we serve are
passionate about the program they
experience profound Improvement to their
health and quality of life through
symptom management from the use of
therapeutic cannabis and they want the
program to be maintained and
improved the program's critical Partners
include the state's licensed medical
providers who are able to integrate
alternative cannabis therapy into their
patients traditional Medical Care other
essential partners are the alternative
treatment centers which are licensed and
regulated by the department for
compliance quality and
safety the TCP is a maturing but
vulnerable program we we regulate a
product in Industry that is federally
illegal and our state is impacted by a
rapidly evolving recreational Cannabis
regional market with a patchwork of
different state
regulations we know that access to
cannabis both therapeutic and
recreational is oftentimes easier and
more afford more affordable across our
borders when the topic of cannabis
legalization in New Hampshire comes up
the questions I'm asked are always the
same what happens to the medical program
when New Hampshire
legalizes why is a medical program even
necessary if New Hampshire legalizes
patients would say that the TCP and the
atcs are critical to their health and
quality of life and they are worried
about what adult use legalization means
for their continued access to this
critical program I would answer with
another
question if New Hampshire values the
state's therapeutic program then how
does it maintain the program
alongside the legal retail sale of
cannabis to
adults we'll try to answer these
questions throughout the presentation by
providing an overview of the TCP by
introducing the patients who find the
program critical to their health and
quality of life and by introducing
essential Partners the
atc's we'll then move some questions to
help establish the importance of
maintaining the Cannabis program
alongside an adult use framework and
lastly we'll talk about the proposed
franchise model and how a dual
regulatory structure can be created
that allows the TCP and the atcs to
maintain the services they provide to
the citizens of New Hampshire we're not
going to cover the broader public health
and behavioral health issues around the
use of cannabis at a population level
but the department would be happy to
come back and have the chance to speak
to the commissions about those broad
broader issues so with that introduction
I invite you to take a take a look at
the slide deck
prepared so as we start the slide deck
and as as Mike prepares to get deeper
into this presentation for us three
things are really important as we're
thinking about the viability and the
importance of the therapeutic cannabis
program with regards to the department
and the more than almost 14,000 people
it serves and those three pillars are
really around patient safety patient
access and patient affordability these
three themes are going to sort of weave
through our presentation over the next
30 minutes or so we encourage you to ask
questions we're we're anxious to hear
hear your thoughts and to be able to
explain any go a little bit deeper in
any one of those areas so again patient
safety patient access patient
affordability so uh page three page
three has the outline we've already gone
through the the structure of the
presentation for you um and when we
start on page four uh the therapeutic
cannabis program was authorized by the N
Hampshire legislature in 2013 um
under real quick as the clerk are you
submit your your your original your
first testimony at opening statement you
made you have that in writing you can
submit it to me I do I I have both of
these documents in writer that I can
submit to the entire commission
digitally thank you after the meeting
thank you um so yeah the TCP was uh was
uh started uh in 2013 uh New Hampshire
was the 20th state to legalize cannabis
for therapeutic use many have followed
in uh after us um and as we know many
states have uh legalized uh cannabis use
for adults um we began issuing registry
ID cards to patients in December of 2015
and the first dispensary in New
Hampshire opened in April of
2016 uh there was no initial
appropriation of funds for the
Department to build this program uh and
no general fund dollars go to support
this program at all their program is
self-funded through patient registration
fees and a ATC licensing
fees currently we have 14,000 patients
and there are seven dispens dispensary
locations in the state from from a
structural point of view the program
when it was originally designed was uh
bifurcated throughout the Department of
Health and Human Services there was a
registry unit there was a rules unit and
none of it was put together we put that
together in 2019 18 and put it under the
division of Public Health Service so we
could have one voice and one regulatory
component right it was split up between
an eligibility arm a licensing arm and a
policy arm um spread out throughout the
department and bringing that program
bringing those elements together in 2018
uh really set the tone for uh the
importance of the program in the
department and if I could just ask if
you could provide some information right
now if a person lives in New Hampshire
doesn't have the uh the registry ID card
what's the process they have to go
through to get that card from the point
where they can actually purchase
therapeutic can yeah we're going to get
we're get to get to that in the
presentation um just very
soon um so the uh the
one question on page six um in terms of
the growth of the program right now so
it looks like obviously there was a
large uptick percentage wise in the
first few years but the um the curve is
somewhat leveled out recently is that
something you expect to maintain like do
you have projections from where you
think that curve will look like in three
years two years five years that is a
theme of our presentation okay um you
know we uh there was uh there was robust
growth in the beginning of the program
and growth has slowed dramatically over
the past three years um alongside the
prolifer proliferation of regional the
regional cannabis market so we're seeing
um we're not seeing declines in patient
registration but we are seeing dramatic
uh lowering of growth um and that
decline in patient registrations is a
Hallmark of states that have uh chosen
to legalize adult use uh patient
registrations fall we're going to be
hearing about this throughout the
presentation thank you and I would just
keep in mind as well that um part of
that steeper slope that you see was as
new conditions were added so each time a
a larger condition something like
chronic pain was added you would see a
spike up and so we are at a place right
now where we have um a large number of
conditions already there it would be to
be expected I think regardless of a
recreational Market that you'd start to
see a slower um like a steadier growth
just simply because you're not adding
larger groups of people who could be
eligible and I assume you the answer is
going to be this is in the presentation
but if you have nearly
14,000 qualifying patients if you had a
recreational sale if you allow to
recreational sales why is there such a
concern that the people receiving this
legitimate treatment would stop using
the therapeutic products and then switch
to the recreational
Market is in the
presentation
get through question at the end um
patients will choose to self patients
will choose to self-medicate patients
don't want to be on a state registry
patients don't want to uh talk to their
doctor about the program they don't want
the application process they don't want
the application fee they don't want the
doctor visit fee and some patients can
afford more expensive recreational
cannabis and so again a highlight of
what's to come one of the things to
maintain a a therapeu Market that's
viable that has the level of um uh
product that may not be as have as much
of a financial incentive that's may not
be a commercial product is to think
about the ways how how expensive the
product is so around taxes and other
things so that's where we're going to
get
to thank you yeah so the TCP has uh some
primary functions it's organized into
two units we have a registra a registry
unit um three staff process patient
applic ations determine eligibility um
issue cannabis registry ID cards we also
have a licensing unit it's made up of
one staff whose responsibility is ATC
licensing uh in uh compliance and
inspection generally speaking the
program's ongoing goals um reducing
barriers to access uh reducing
administrative burden for both patients
in the application process and atcs to
get out of the way so that they can do
business uh maintaining compliance of
the atc's and also increasing product
quality and product safety um you should
also know that there is a medical
oversight board that is associated with
the therapeutic cannabis program that
was formed in 20 uh that was
legislatively authorized in 2018 um in
response to the need for clinical
oversight of the program membership
includes 10 uh uh clinical members
representing various Specialties and
their purpose is to provide General
oversight to the clinical quality and
public health related matters of the
Cannabis program specifically uh they
have spent a lot of time and the
legislative charges to review new
conditions and to evaluate current
medical conditions um for their
continued
appropriateness um so yes as we were
talking about patient enrollment um as
of June 30th the end of the fiscal year
we have about 14,000 patients on the
program uh like we've said we've seen
steady uh steady growth for a number of
years um significant growth after we
after the legislature added chronic pain
and PTSD at that point um those two
conditions alone doubled the the the
population
roles so with your chart here is there
any data on people that have been
removed from the program and and can you
lose your card can you have your
privileges removed is there a system in
place for that uh we don't we don't keep
data on the number of people who don't
renew their cards
so these increases are net increases
okay so there potentially could be
people that have came off the system but
they're still included in in these
numbers no these numbers are a snapshot
of patient registration on June 30th at
the end of our state fiscal year this is
the data that we use to um populate our
annual report um we've had about
30,000 maybe 35,000 patients over the
course of the entire program
um and many many many patients choose
not to renew um due to them dying or
cannabis is not working for them um or
or a variety of other reasons the cost
they can't afford it Etc so we don't
track necessarily or published the
number of people who are no longer on
the program um uh but this is current
state um uh population um registration
to answer your second question um yeah
the department has the authority uh and
the respons responsibility of revoking
uh denying applications um and also
revoking cards for uh various violations
of the statute um and and we have it is
rare but it has
happened question oh
sorry the followup to be to be clear
your statement was there's been 35,000
30 to 35,000 individual patients over
the course of the life of the program
that have made made access the medical
cannabis program some of obviously those
have Fall Fallen off for various reasons
but that's the gross number of New
Hampshire citizens that have had access
to the program 30 to 35,000 yes I would
like to confirm that number uh when I
send the the the the documents to the
the organization um it's not like I said
it's not a number we track and publish
um I'd like to confirm that number uh my
memory says it's about 35,000 thank
you um and just to clarify you're you
can't distinguish of those 30,000 how
many left because they passed away it
didn't work or they couldn't afford it
there's no way to figure out what those
might look like there is a program rule
uh supported by a um the statute that
requires um the department to be
notified when a patient is
deceased uh but it is ex it is
impossible to enforce um some patient we
we do get calls on a regular basis um
when uh when when when patients die uh
it's usually when um we send out renewal
notices um and and we and we find out
that the patients the patients family
members will call in and say you know
can you stop sending us notices to my
dead husband say um you know and the
other other reasons why we we have no
way of accessing patients um who other
patients who have left the program for
any other reason so no we don't collect
that data okay
thanks yes good morning uh do you have
any records or data on uh the number of
people who have been denied a license in
your program and the reasons why there
was a denial if
any I don't have that today I can tell
you that it's very few patients who are
denied um but we can I can find that out
um it is it is remarkably few patients
who are denied the department does not
do a clinical review we are not
clinicians um our eligibility
determination is largely a paperwork um
eligibility process where uh if we if if
the application uh elements are complete
the doctor has signed off um in you know
on a three p you know three-page form
it's a cumbersome application process um
people are approved it is very rare when
uh when when patients are denied the
program there are a great number of
people who apply to the program and
never complete their application process
uh they would be in incomplete status uh
they have the it has the effect of not
getting a card um but they are not
denied based on fraud or uh some program
violation follow question Mr shair so
would it be fair to say then that the
vast majority of applicants um receive
permission for therapeutic marijuana
would that be fair to say yes it is and
one more followup question Mr chair and
I would just qualify that by the the
applicants who complete an application
with their provider signature on it uh
and and is it true that to obtain a card
that a doctor does not write or a
medical practitioner does not write a
prescription because that's um would be
uh illegal uh based on their medical
license and their DEA registration is
that correct that is true New Hampshire
law does not require a provider to
prescribe cannabis newshire Law requires
certifying medical providers to certify
that one of their patients has been
diagnosed with one of the qualifying
conditions listed in state law so then
it's fair to say then doctors only
certifying that a patient has a
condition and is not prescribing uh
cannabis but only indicating a condition
because the practitioner is prescribed
and it cannot issue prescri prescrition
for cannabis is that correct cannabis is
not a f FDA approved medication
currently it's a schedule one uh
controlled substance and providers as
you say would
be it would be
illegal to prescribe an FDA thank you Mr
chair control substance that is schedule
one um so right as we've seen um patient
growth has flat LED um uh in 2020 there
were 200 there were 2400 net new
patients in 2020 there were 500 net new
patients so over the past three years
we've seen a a steep decline in growth
uh caregivers um caregivers are are
people friends and family who apply for
cards and are allowed to legally possess
cannabis on behalf of their patient um
there right now there's almost a
thousand um in 2023 that number doubled
from about 500 to almost a thousand
because of a legislative change that
removed uh administrative barrier to
accessing caregiver status and that was
uh the legislature removing the
requirement for a federal fingerprinting
and background check they maintain the
requirement for no felony conviction but
they remove the uh the requirement for a
federal background check um caregivers
cannot cultivate nobody can cultivate
cannabis in uh New Hampshire unlike in
many other states especially Maine which
has a robust caregiver uh model that is
built on uh caregiver
cultivation um so and the other uh
registration category we have is medical
providers um currently about, 1300
medical providers have certified at
least one current patient um over the
course of the program just like patient
numbers you know we've seen you know uh
far more um maybe up to 2,000 again I'd
have to confirm that number um but as of
as June 30th uh 1300 patients have
certified um a a patient that growth has
been you know modest maybe a 100 per
year you know since over the past few
years um if you go to the next slide we
get a great picture of what our patients
look like um the majority of patients
are in their 50s and 60s um we uh that's
that's an area where you would expect to
see the uh you know the the disease
State or the condition State um chronic
pain is is a very you know Common
condition amongst that age population so
just just to clarify the scope of what
the commi the commission's covering here
uh is to study the purpose of proposing
legislation uh for State controlled
sales of the Cannabis and canvas
products I understand that the
therapeutic side of things is very
complicated industry and and there's a
lot of regulations and I understand a
lot of that's in the slides we can
review that but the main focus what we
would want to hear about is if there was
retail how would you incorporate the two
uh some of the history and I understand
this I see patient testimonials U I
think if you don't mind for the sake of
efficiency we kind of want to get to the
meat of why we're what the scope of the
commission is certainly we can we can um
Quicken our pace and and Skip some of
these slides testing labeling we we
understand this those are existing
regulations already in place but how
would you incorporate all that into a
retail
Market maybe Jump Ahead to like page 22
which is where we start getting into how
medical industry interacts with the
potential State
model our our attempt here is to
establish the value of the program and
the importance of maintaining the
therapeutic program um and and in and
yes certainly jump ahead but I I I do
want to impress upon you know the the
the commission that um we have a we have
a highly regulated mature program that
has you know that has been doing this
for seven years it's very important to
patients um we have uh strict
requirements on testing packaging um uh
product safety um and these are these
are important things to consider um for
any commission member who may be
thinking that well those questions that
I started with which is why do we even
need this program um so I I I want I we
did want to emphasize this I I urge you
all to take uh take your time and look
through the slides to to to to absorb
that message through the slides that
we'll be uh that we'll be skipping so
just just to get right to the point
I if there was a retail Market whether
it's private retail the franchise model
complete State
Control there's no intention of the at
least on my end to for this to make the
therapeutic industry insolvent so the
idea is if you're going to how would you
incorporate that into legislation so
that wouldn't
happen it's my understanding that the
the therapeutic industry believes that
they would lose some of their patients
to the retail
Market which could already be happening
I mean if there people buying out of
state whether it's Maine or mass
Massachusetts but what's the best thing
that we can do any suggestions on how to
allow everyone to coexist in in harmony
so if I might back up to one question
prior to that and that is what are the
differences between an adult use model
and a therapeutic model um to kind of
preview the the transitioning into you
know what do we suggest for uh uh for
integration or dual regulatory structure
a little a little leway you know to to
to to talk about the fundamental
differences between between and adult
use model um uh so one is access to
therapeutic products um the therapeutic
programs and this is this is page 16 so
just a just a just a few few additional
slides if I might uh
Senator
um the therapeutic products um and
strains are products that are not sold
in uh recreational markets uh their low
THC strains and products their CBD Rich
strains their ratio products products
that have both THC and CBD they have
therapeutic routes of administration
like suppositories these are
non-profitable you know uh these are
non-profitable uh product type that
would never be sold in a in a
recreational uh market and so that
that's contributes to the reason why
it's important to maintain you know
these uh these this this model um
therapeutic programs allow higher
potency products higher dose per serving
products because those higher uh
potencies and higher doses are needed
for Effective symptom
management uh access to therapeutic
education about cannabis which is not
expected you know in a recreational Mo
uh uh model in the therapeutic World
being high is an adverse side effect uh
the Mantra is go low start slow uh the
atc's uh have a critical educational
message of what is the minimum amount of
cannabis necessary to achieve a desired
effect these are not the kind of
education that is going to be offered in
a uh in adult use
Market why do you let me ask this the
person that's providing the education in
the therapeutic facility when someone
goes there what is their training and
background uh the state does not
prescribe a training model or mechanism
for them um they are experts in their
own products uh and and they uh much of
their much of their training is uh
experiential based on the the the the
testimonials and the and the
effectiveness surveys that they run with
patients uh they're they know which
products help other patients and they
sit down with patients and um and and
identify products that may be useful it
is trial and error uh but to answer your
question no there's no formal training
that the state requires uh for for for
that for those
staff thank you uh so I I you said it
and I just want to make sure I make sure
so which of these products here are
you're saying that are not sold in a
recreational because they're not
profitable that that that they're not
did people wouldn't buy them you said
something about that there's not enough
money to be made or you you use that I
mean one one good example would be
suppositories it's not a recreational
product but some people can't some
people simply are too too sick to be
able to take cannabis in any other form
um the others are strains of th strains
of cannabis that have under 10% of THC
um it's not a recreational product um
and you would not find uh strains that
have that low amount of THC in a recre I
thought the some states they like
Massachusetts it's five it has to be 5%
or less no that's uh what what to
clarify what that is is uh milligrams of
THC per serving okay so a fruit chew or
a lazing in Massachusetts can't have
more than five milligrams per piece of
um of products um what I'm talking about
is actual strains um and and products uh
cannabis infused products that have
higher doses of CBD um higher uh uh
percentages of CBG um and and and
whatnot and these are non-med or these
are non-recreational
cannabinoids right but that but some
having let's say one%
milligram is is that available in in
Massachusetts I mean you said 5% or less
I
mean uh yes I believe that there are low
dose lowow low dose milligrams per
serving in mass m mints are a typical
you know uh product just talking about
the amount of THC that was you I guess
it's a little confusing to me Senator
Lang bring the conversation back a
little bit so we don't wander field
farfield the I don't think whether it
was 639 and the amendments to 639 or
1598 has the intention of doing away
with the medical cannabis program I
think the question is the interaction of
the two programs and to make sure that
if we want to allow things like the THC
the the um the at atcs to operate a
retail store as a franchise model
are there changes that are necessary in
statute because I understand the atcs
have to be nonprofit and there are
things around that meod so I guess to
bring the focus back and and what I was
hoping for out of this conversation is I
want to make sure we find those
crossovers where we put a law in place
but there's another law somewhere else
that makes it so atcs can't can't open a
retail Market that'll help them keep
their medical Market viable as well so
again if we can bring the conversation
into that area as where the interaction
is between 639 and 159 8 and the medical
cannabis program where those two might
cross and how we can craft legislation
to protect any conflicts thank you for
that redirect Senator Lang and represent
Kay have question yeah so I was I was
reading in one of the slides we skipped
over you have you're allowed to have
four of these locations in the state is
that how is that what you have state law
allows for a maximum of four ATC
licenses those licenses have been
awarded to three not for profit entities
so one entity has two of those licenses
the law also prescribes the number of
dispensary locations that are allowed in
the state and that is uh originally that
was four um and in 2018 and 2019 the
legislature increase that number uh to
uh to eight So currently there are seven
uh and the eighth location is
pending have you seen in other states
that have have a both recreational
program and a therapeutic
program have you seen the therapeutic
programs hurt by the recreational
program patient registration declines
are a Hallmark of States who have a
medical program and then move to
legalization um preliminary data shows
15 out of the 17 states that have
legalized that have publicly available
reliable data about patient
registrations have seen a decline of
average of
31% um if you take out the uh the number
of new markets the ones that have just
been uh um that they're not matured um
that that decline goes up to 40% but the
range of declines that have experienced
by States you know are go up you know
from the the from the tens to the
90s um if we take the average of 30%
decrease then 14,000
patients I'm not going to attempt to do
the math in my head but uh it is it is
it is expected that patients will leave
the program um on uh if there's a
legalization available in uh New
Hampshire if I could just CL clarify one
I I I don't think this was answered so
you have a person that works in the
therapeutic center who is an expert
apparently on on the whatever they're
Distributing all right now at any
nutritional supplement store you know
think of like a vitamin shop GN C same
thing the people working there are
selling supplements for all sorts of
different ailments whether it's immunity
Health joint health protein shakes
whatever that that the last time I went
to one of those stores the person
working there uh didn't graduate from
high school yet so they knew the
products they were selling they may not
know the reason why this boosts your
immune system or why this will you know
make you stronger help you recover but
they know what the product does so I'm
I'm just trying to if if you're banking
on the fact that people are relying on
what the person in the store is saying
uh in other therapeutic products that un
relate to cannabis I I think the
consumers aren't
necessarily as Reliant as you may think
I understand there may be more
complicated medical issues to some of
the patients here but to make the entire
model reliant on the expert of the
person in the basically making the
transaction I'm trying to figure out
what are they bringing to the table here
that's keeping everyone going there and
how many of those patients are even
relying on that I mean if you have a
history of migraines I think you know
after the first interaction with them
you understand what you're doing right
so they may end up going to the
recreational Market anyway because they
know what they
need so I don't know that we know that I
think what we find again with the vast
um number of different conditions that
are here of whether you're have cancer
whether you have chronic pain whether
you have an immune other immune system
so to your point the folks that work
there have experience with the market I
I think your analogy to GNC is is
interesting but I do know that those um
atcs also have clinical representation
in their in their organizations that
help inform that it makes it harder in
um a when we have uh that the Cannabis
is federal L illegal that you can't have
broader discussions you have fewer
opportunities for sort of credentialed
education so I don't know that comparing
that always makes sense um I do know
that one of the Hallmarks of the program
also is to try and connect with the
medical provider and when the program
works best the patient is working both
with their ATC and with their own
provider in order to get to the right
results I to to the point though I want
to make sure that we hurry up In
fairness can you there has been some
scient ific research or studies on the
benef potential benefits of cannabis so
they say that you can't compare it to a
a protein shake there been they all list
that on the products too what studies
have been done on what supplements so I
think there's been enough that they at
least have a basis for the
recommendation I'm just trying to figure
out do we really believe that relying on
the expertise of the person working
there is essential to the sustainability
of the therapeutic industry that's what
I'm trying to get at I don't I don't
believe it is I'm just trying to I I
think it plays an important part to to
the quantity I I can't give you the
quantity of what to what degree
especially when you have people who are
naive to cannabis use coming in you have
a 70-year-old woman who hasn't perhaps
had cannabis ever or last time in 1969
they're riant on some information from
someone else who has experience what we
would like to talk to and to your point
earlier is really about the Dual
regulatory structure about the ideas
that we have around how the two can work
together and I think first of all if we
sort of jump to 26 then um some of those
and Mike can jump in here is
understanding in your legislation that
there's clear language that establishes
that the atcs are permitted to apply for
the recreational market so just to get
to financial Li um Level Playing ground
that we want to make sure that there's
some opportunity for them to play I
think we are looking at ideas around
separate and specific rul making
authority to allow use for these dual
use or um integrated licenses we have
organizations that are already set up
they've already invested in the capital
in their structure in their gross sites
we want to make sure that that's
acknowledged and that there's
opportunities in the legislation to
align regulations and establish some
accommodations and finally very
specifically we want to harmonize
Laboratory Testing requirements to
ensure safety there's opportunity in our
current rule statute and rules to update
those Laboratory Testing and I think it
makes sense to me make it all the same
with the recreational Market take it
from there yeah so um there are some
elements of the uh so generally speaking
the franchise model that was proposed by
The Liquor Commission a couple weeks ago
um appears to be a model that would
allow for uh the atcs to enter the
market they you know they they they
stated that atcs would be welcome to
apply for any license type um that they
choose to like anyone else you know to
to to piggy back on what Trisha has said
is that um but they're not like everyone
else because they're currently operating
under a regulatory structure um in
statute and in in in in rule um some of
the elements that we um that we see that
were part of that presentation um
include um like include branding you
know uh New Hampshire uh cannabis
branding where we would ask uh
consideration of you know an allowance
to maintain their current brand patients
need to know that their going to the
same store that they've been going to
for the past seven years um and so it is
there are opportunities for integrating
the the New Hampshire cannabis brand
into their current branding um but we
would ask for uh consideration of
allowing them to maintain um uh their
their own brand um another thing that
was stated uh a couple weeks ago was uh
with regard to retail locations um in
locals o which have only in which have a
currently have a liquor store well we
would encourage an evaluation of the
current retail locations of the atcs um
for Align purposes we know that Chai
Chester which has a dispensary does not
have a liquor store so that becomes you
know uh an area of of consideration you
know perhaps most importantly um we
would we would say that the 15%
franchise fee that's proposed by The
Liquor Commission um we would like an
exploration of our opportunity
opportunities to exempt therapeutic
sales from that 15% uh of fee so these
are just some of the examples based on
the presentation we heard that that we
would encourage uh the commission to
look at when we are align when when
they're wri when you all are writing the
legislation um in terms of a more
granular level you know what
we're what we're what we're looking at
is once we have a a draft of what this
commission
proposes we the department need to
crosswalk that Proposal with RSA
126x um to uh to figure out where there
are barriers um that the it is is going
to be important to remove barriers
remove areas of conflict and in areas
where we can't remove areas of conflict
to create specific accommodations for
the atc's so that they can enter the
market um it would be very easy for
barriers to exist to say well if you
can't meet that requirement then you
then you can't enter the market and so
that's what we that's what we would ask
is you know to give us an opportunity
and the atc's an opportunity to
crosswalk whatever legislation uh draft
is proposed um you know and and and
provide suggestions on areas for
alignment and accommodation and I think
that there are opportunities both with
whatever draft that you will propose for
conversation in there and then also just
looking at 126 X that there may be
changes that we suggest should go in
there Laboratory Testing is a great
example where we want to modernize that
and harmonize it with whatever it is
that you propose there's also something
in our current um you know around not
for-profit status we don't have an
opinion on that but it is something to
consider around whether we maintain not
for-profit status for the therapeutic
Market I just want to clarify it and I'm
going to reach over to commissioner Mal
over there um my understanding is that
from from your presentation that the
locations weren't set based on where
liquor store was it was just a total
number of dispens of dispensaries
whatever you want to call them was set
by the total number of liquor stores is
that correct that's correct and it
wasn't your intention on a 15% franchise
fee to require medical dispensaries to
pay that fee it was only for any retail
version that the dispensary may open
they would be required for the retail
sales within that to pay the 15% that's
correct thank you chief
yes
um what is the gross uh cost of
Regulation and running the department
this program to the taxpayers of the
State of New Hampshire
currently zero zero like I said uh
earlier there is no general fund
appropriation for the support of the
program the the program is 100% entirely
supported by patient fees and ATC
licensing fees and has been since 2013
you're an employee of DHHS correct I am
and your salary is paid by whom the
therapeutic cannabis program and how
many employees are 100% devoted to the
therapeutic cannabis program whose
salaries are paid by DHHS if you know
currently five and do you know what the
gross costs of that compensation uh in
module for office space I do not have
that number in front of me right now but
I can provide our uh our annual budget
to you in a in a followup so would it be
fair to say then that all the products
if this commission were to recommend all
the products that currently are
available in the TCP
program could be required under a retail
program that it would be a net savings
to the
taxpayer uh by simply folding this
program into the retail program and
making requirements to maintain the same
products and the same type of products
correct no taxpayers don't pay for this
this this uh
program no I I think what what what I'm
saying is is that this the commission
could promulgate rules or require or
recommend I should say rules and
regulations that would require the same
products that you say are not available
in retail stores elsewhere that would be
required to be sold in retail stores in
by the franchisees in New Hampshire that
would be possible correct that would be
a policy decision for this commission it
would not be a recommended policy
consideration from the perspective of um
therapeutic cannabis program uh the K
atc's and uh patients who who require
therapeutic products require therapeutic
education um there's an access issue as
well where the program serves uh the
therapeutic program serves people who
are under 21 and there no medic no adult
use Market allows a population of under
21 to enter their stores you know we've
got about 200 patients
um under 21 they would be shut out of
the program without you know without the
maintenance of the at the ATC system and
the TCP system you know kids get cancer
too you know and and it would be it it
would be problematic to exclude them
from access to uh this critical
alternative therapy and is it also fair
to say then that the same people that
you described as having experiential but
no formal education with respect to um
therapeutic cannabis that work in these
stores could also be employed by retail
stores uh would that be fair to
say of
course so uh in essence then all the
products as well as the Personnel that
are currently employed uh in atcs could
also be employed and provided in a uh
commercial retail program if the
commission were to so recommend and the
state were to so adopt one would that be
correct that would not be a recommended
approach from the Department's
perspective but but it is possible
correct it is it is possible with uh
accommodations that we've talked about
in terms of minor and under 21 access
Senate again sen again you recognize
thank you um just refresh me if you will
I'm trying to remember about six years
ago and we had a earlier marijuana
commission did we not set up the atc's
so they would never compete in an open
retail Market wasn't that one of the
promises that it would be an unfair
advantage to the commercial Market that
you guys would already get set up so I
thought you had promise that you would
never go retail and that you were going
to serve a niche market and that the two
worlds would never meet do I the
department the I was in those I was in
the gallery in those uh the previous
commission meetings uh we were not
members of that commission um I so we
never made the promise that we would
never we never made that commitment um
publicly and I don't recall that uh
commitment being being discussed um it
was discussed I just don't remember I
didn't remember that you weren't a part
yet okay thank you
okay uh we're going to surprise you here
let first start out let's first start
out with the concept that you can only
have one
master so therefore the question is can
the ATC
program operate as it is now Ru making
done through
HHS uh nonprofit status so that it
maintains the the low cost for the
product we keep everything exactly the
same and no is not about retail at all
retail is a totally different
statute totally different
customer totally different
Marketplace that we make sure
that we don't create the conflicts
clearly the department can uh when they
see the uh Liquor Commission come up
with new rules about testing you
certainly can have a hearings and decide
to have the
same that's already in statute so if we
just say right now atcs don't have to
pay the 15% atc's continue to operate
just as they are just they if they want
to come forward and say we want to
expand in the future they can still do
that can always come back to the
legislature and say we want more stores
more locations more whatever but why not
just treat this as leave you alone let
you do your thing you clearly uh are
doing a market Niche there's a unique
customers who want your product and
therefore it should be competitive uh
the model that we have already created
to say is oh no the state's creating
another model that's going to hurt
us is only because the customer has
chosen to switch we the legislature
should not do anything to change the ATC
program just as it
is would you
agree well Mike is deciding whether or
not he agrees um I I
think I think that is that is certainly
an approach that you can take what I
think we could also direct you to
there's some ver there's some lessons
from the Vermont model so our neighbor
to the west they've developed an
integrated license they have separate
license categories available to only
existing centers they allowed
therapeutic entities to apply for one
single vertical uh vertically integrated
license and and so that's another path
that you could consider but that would
grire them then have to pay the 15% if
they chose the other model model but
this model because you're a nonprofit
because you are who you are because the
statute is working
right why would we mess with that why
don't we just leave you alone let you do
your thing and uh and if there's a
problem in the future the legislature
can fix it but I at this point we're
going to exempt you from the 15% because
you're different targeting a different
customer the customer is required to
have to have a a piece of paper signed
by a doctor where the retail customers
don't it's a totally different model and
if I can just maybe just simplify the
statement you're making basically are
are you saying that no one's asking the
atc's to enter the retail Market they're
asking to enter the retail market and
therefore they should be subject to the
retail regulations if they choose to
stay out of the retail market then it's
business as usual agreed Senator B other
states have other states have considered
these you know these same questions as
we're considering right now and um and
there are a number of different uh uh
approaches um the Vermont model you know
allowed at their their equivalent of the
atc's to apply for an integrated license
um other states have chosen to uh create
a new agency within their state um you
know with uh with room for both the
adult use uh model and the recreation
model other states are do are
considering exactly what you know New
Hampshire's considering you know with
regard to The Liquor Commission you know
being responsible for adult use sales um
and another agency like the Department
of Health um uh regulating um uh the um
the the Medical Market um most of those
States Al if not all of those states
have allowed the medical entities to
enter the me uh the adult use Market um
for a number of reasons but one of them
is if they're not allowed
to I'll I'll I'll pause there the the
the commission the commission has the
charge to solicit input from the atc's
um and the atc's can speak much more
clearly and directly about their
business model you know they can speak
about at what level of patient
participation will result in staff
leaving reduction of services reduction
of products reduction of the patient
affordability programs Etc you know
they'd be much more uh um Adept at
giving you an inside look at their um
their particular industry and the risks
of not being allowed to enter this
Market we're not we're not saying that
the commission has to go with that model
what we're trying to do with many with
most of the slides that we did not get
to is that what happens when patient
registrations decline we have a weaker
ATC system and which has the potential
for disrupting the service to those
patients who absolutely need the ATC
model in order to continue accessing
these products so all of the models
apparently are on the table with this
commission um and we're here to give
Prov provide information we're happy to
provide more information and come back
as we as this commission gets closer to
what it decides as a uh as as a desired
model for New
Hampshire yeah fundamentally I mean it
goes back to those three things from the
Department of Health and Human Services
we want to make sure that there's access
to the product certainly you want to
have a competitive environment where
those entities decide to stay open
because if you create a system in which
it is impossible for them to keep the
doors open then it closes and the
product goes away so really it goes back
to we want safe product we want it to be
accessible we want it to be affordable
we look to you as the commission to to
set the tone and set the direction of
where you go and we're happy to
crosswalk 126k with whatever Direction
you go do you want us to make the the
first move we were ask it would be
helpful if you just told us how to do it
and we got right to the point that would
save us probably one full day of
hearings but Dr Dr
jren
yeah thank you that's a that's a great
question and that would be part of the
alignment of Regulation um uh when we
crosswalk the the the proposal and the
the 126x which is the therapeutic
program we we would Advocate and for
consideration
of consideration of of certain
principles and a prioritization of
Service delivery to our patients you
know separate uh separate counters say
um uh for sale um lower prices
guaranteed therapeutic inventory
maintaining or at at at the least
maintaining the breadth of therapeutic
products um you know and increasing them
ensuring a lower price for therapeutic
products these are the kinds of things
that we uh the department would have as
priorities for a dual use or a dual
regulatory structure model where the
atcs are serving both populations um
States uh there there are examples
throughout the country where these kinds
of requirements are in uh state law um
that we don't have to reinvent the wheel
here on on maintaining um that balance
of a priorization of serving therapeutic
patients if the atcs are allowed to also
sell to a retail
market so yeah we we be I'm very
interested in going through that list of
uh priorities for prioritizing you know
cannabis patients you know with you and
the commission as we get to a granular
level of drafting this
legislation just same one after the
other so the same way thank you Mr chair
so uh fair to say then just going back
that ultimately every state that has uh
legalized the sale of retail cannabis if
there was a predecessor therapeutic can
program uh it was significantly dimin
diminished if not um um
ultimately becomes um an economical
eom
I can prev perhaps te up um you know
some of the information that you will
receive from the at
commission
proval data on this question so I urge
you to
um he fromc directly they will be
absolutely primed to provide direct
specific examples of
and the experience of other states thank
you uh for your answer uh it open source
information certainly indicates that the
main therapeutic canvas industry has all
but collapsed
correct that that's not my experience
I'm not an expert in Maine um M have a
very different model for their medical
program um data shows that they have uh
coupls to 100,000 register Pati office
of
Canabis policy does not require
registration with the state of the
patient but uh does require the
providers to issue those certifications
report the member certifications they
have
100,000
in again I don't have sales data in
front of me um I would I
impr model
model
they are not required to test their
products for pesticides
contaminants can choose to be AER and
marijuana whatever PTI they want to put
in it's
not but it is still still important to
the patients of main even though they
may be getting
consum unfortunately their policy
choices have imp our state Pati you
know unul
marijana if you could suspend if you can
suspend for just a moment so at some
point we're going to go through HP 1598
as a amended from last term if you can
provide some information to this
commission right now how the atcs can
integrate into this that's why we want
to have a kind of a floor to work with
I'm not so you have something to look at
you want to take a look at that maybe
provide some suggestions on how that
would work
Mr
it's real quick so again to wrap I want
to kind of close up the conversation a
little bit and just say that the atcs
are not my understanding of the summary
of your question is
that the idea that you could have a
potential separate retail license that's
integrated with an existing medical
you're not objecting to that you you
think that's a reasonable model and then
the followup with that is that on page
31 you do provide some incredible uh
clear um public health issues that you
want to see integrated into the Bill
thank you okay next question
thank you Mr chair I have a child safety
issue relating to uh advertising
accountability and oversight of the
atc's um I I know the the leg the
original statute uh that established the
atc's prohibited advertising and
Outreach which very smart and and we're
talking the same thing with with um the
recreational model uh the question I
have is that um
we have an ATC that was established in
Plymouth
right n eight nine years ago and um they
were
non-compliant with that uh Ru making so
they were actually advertising when I
look at page seven and I noticed that
the the majority of your sales go to age
uh 35 through 74 the patients yet they
were adver in purple train wreck which
is a Prov provocative uh name for a
medicine and most cancer patients would
not be looking for purple train wre uh
yet that's very interesting to to kids
and they will also do an Outreach on the
college a complaint was filed it was
dismissed um so it was no surprise to
our community within two years the
Adolescent youth use of marijuana
increased by
88% this is a major issue that the
commission has been discussing uh to
protect our children so my question is
it comes as far as oversight uh I think
that it it's lacking clearly you know
with the atc's yet and I heard
commissioner mikica state that if there
is a a
non-compliance with with any of these
issues they would lose their license so
I would like to know um in addition to
um the oversight sole oversight of the
New Hampshire Liquor Commission will we
be discussing an oversight Commission in
addition uh and I think that that's
something we should
consider as a
commission okay so that that's my
question I said you know basically will
there be an oversight uh commission that
has teeth
that's really going to protect our
children when it comes to uh monitoring
the
franchisees uh because I don't believe
we have proper monit monitoring of the
atc's and we want to make sure that we
strengthen our uh protective uh
protection of our children thank
you thank you um so I think you had
mentioned earlier um of the 30 like
Universe of 30,000 total patients that
have been in the the program that you
all administer at least some of them
have left because it didn't work or they
couldn't afford the product and I'm
wondering you had mentioned I think 30%
it's about a 30% reduction in people who
are in the program and states that move
from Le U marijuana uh medical marijuana
to legal recreational you had said
earlier and I'm curious has anyone done
like an actual like um academic
qualitative review of that 30% and
whether or not that 30% are less
satisfied with the outcome um when they
left the therapeutic program and went
into like whatever however their
purchasing now through the retail Market
I understand the
question if I if I understand the
question I I I I do not know of an
academic study with regard to
why former registered patients leave the
program um I am aware of
a
of an abstract of a um a study that
shows those decreases um but I'm not
aware of an analysis of the reason
why ju so I just want to clarify then so
we're not sure then that 30% are less
satisfied so we just know that 30% left
the program but they could be equally
satisfied or more satisfied with the the
treatment the services they're getting
currently we can we can speculate we
have some good ideas of why they would
leave um uh cost M cost y it's a $50
application fee in some cases providers
are charging hundreds of dollars for the
privilege of you know a half hour you
know meeting for a certification um uh
there's a proliferation
of relatively inexpensive cannabis right
across our borders for anyone 21 and
over people don't want to be on our
state registry we have just in the
interest of time my understand just
correct me if I'm wrong unless the the
person dies there's no survey or data
collected why the person didn't renew
their license that is correct
okay representative
Sullivan thank you so it sounds like the
the real concern that you guys have is
if we legalize it across the state
regardless of model then the atc's could
be in danger of potentially not being
able to provide the products they they
currently provide
because they be in competition and some
of the businesses would leave some of
the business would leave to these new
stores is that the Crux the concern that
okay so so one of the suggestions you
you brought up was maybe to have a dual
license or what was it called the
Vermont system whatever integated
license right so I guess my question is
you had said something about there maybe
being dual Windows within you know the
ATC window and then the body else window
or something like that that was
something you just said recently right
like that could be a potential model so
I guess my question is if our goal and I
think this this is a noble goal but if
our goal is to be able to continue to
provide these sort of therapeutic
products that would not otherwise be
available in a in a retail for-profit
model would that still suffice so if you
have a ATC under the same roof as a
franchise or however we end up doing it
in New Hampshire
are those products going to still I mean
it seems to me like we're we're facing
the same problem there's a reason that
these atcs can't survive in their own
under the current regulatory framework
putting putting an ATC under the same
roof of a franchise or other system does
that solve that problem or does it still
get out competed away or put out of
business or whatever and and I know you
don't a step towards solving the problem
what's that it's a step towards solving
the problem is there evidence from
Vermont that it has it has solve the
problem or do a bunch of adcs still
close down or is there another I'm
trying to figure if it works or not ver
Vermont has Vermont had three uh license
facilities uh we have um three license
facilities um all of the at all the atcs
all the Compassionate Care Centers in in
in Vermont are still operational um in
part because they're allowed to sell uh
Adult Ed cannabis and representative I
don't believe we were provided any
actual materials or evidence that the
atcs would actually become insolvent
they're afraid that they'll become
insolvent but even the the reduction in
uh licenses or whatever you want to
therapeutic cards that's under the
presumption that every person with a
cards using or spending the same amount
of money so we haven't had any
information provided to us and and what
that amount would have to be to the
point but they argue that it would be
cheaper I'd offer one more data point if
you will just one moment please the
other side of it is too A lot of these
therapeutic facilities would be in a
position where they could cultivate and
perhaps sell their distribute their
products to other retail stores so they
would have another Market that they're
not even factoring into their solvency
so there's a lot more information we'll
hear we'll have a day where I'm sure the
atcs will provide us with a lot of
information on that that subject
representative uh to follow off I guess
on the last question and it sounds as
though that one of the difficulties for
the atcs then in a recreational model
where an at and and a recreational
facility would have to compete is that
the ATC is actually providing
insufficient incentive for a patient to
continue to go to the ATC in light of
the recreational facility is that
correct your question is the atcs are
providing insufficient motivation
for M
maintaining patronage at a ATC uh to
that it is providing insufficient
incentives to the patient to continue to
go to the ATC versus the uh Recreational
facility
I think that is a concern I just want to
be clear that the department and I'm
going to sound like a broken record our
goal is to ensure that there's access to
these products the atcs themselves can
speak to their business model in a much
more elegant way than we can we just
want to make sure that we have we have
14,000 very sick people in the state who
use these products and we want to make
sure that it's available and we want to
work with this commission to do that
sort of crosswalk to the legislation to
ensure we're not putting up unnecessary
barriers so in respect to HB 1598 as
amended from last term yes how would the
what suggestions do you have that would
allow the atcs to integrate into that
piece of
legislation a dual regulatory structure
I mean uh The Liquor Commission uh
proposed the general model where a
franchise model where any any entity any
person including the atcs could apply
for a license and our our our position
is is that in order for an ATC to apply
like anyone else they are currently
under a regulatory structure that you
know that needs to be changed or
accommodated with those changes what
would you change I'm sorry and and so
and so what the the work that needs to
be to be done is a crosswalk between uh
1598 and 126 and we can bring that back
to you we're happy to do and bring that
back to
you we just did we are looking for your
direction very specific that was not the
specific direction we were given but if
with that's the direction we can bring
that back to
you yeah and I I I I just want to
apologize because I know that you have
all this in your presentation I just
feel like we haven't let you get to them
so I'm wondering if you want to go back
to number 30 where you were page 30
where you you are answering all of our
questions in a very organized way we'll
be happy to at the pleasure of the chair
I've asked that question myself not in
the same context but did I've asked the
question multiple times please do
so
the uh so considerations for an Ali
system establishing a cannabis Advisory
Board representing diverse interests to
oversee the uh development on operation
of the program and that integration um
support for a preliminary and ongoing
public education campaign about the
risks of cannabis use responsible use
safe use storage Etc support for
prevention treatment and Recovery
efforts data collection and monitoring
including current Baseline data prior to
adult use uh retail implementation
additional Public Health considerations
that we would want in uh considered in
uh the legislation are independent
Testing Laboratories uh license holders
of retail markets should not be testing
their own products uh robust testing
requirements for potency and
contaminants accurate labeling for
potency child resistant Packaging
reasonable serving size limits 5
milligrams of THC per serving for
instance uh potential potency limits for
certain Recreational Products strict
advertising restrictions especially with
regard to miners Universal symbols on
labels advertising and uh again certain
specific products diversion controls
like electronic seed to sell inventory
systems limitations on public
consumption especially smoking and
vaping in public uh and the continued
prohibition on unregulated hemp THC
products a lot of these issues are
issues are are are were in the liquor
commission's presentation um not all of
them were um areas of accommodation and
Alignment include uh exemption from the
15% franchise free consideration of
maintaining the atc's current Brands um
ATC uh uh DHS DHHS priorization with
regard to uh if there is a dual lure
require them to prioritize serving um uh
ATC p uh uh therapeutic cannabis
patients um these are the areas I cannot
tell you right now what where
specifically in 589 1589 these
Provisions belong but the the back half
of this presentation has has these
examples of areas of uh regulatory
alignment and accommodation uh to
allow atcs to enter this market and
we're happy to do that crosswalk with
five with1 1589 and again with the final
product um or final draft product that
the commission comes up with and do you
have any recommendation on
on if you have a product that's purely
just CBD without any THC in there would
that fa you think that's your fall
outside
uh these
regulations I can tell you what we do
now um I CBD is CBD is available
everywhere it is a ferally legal
substance it's available everywhere um
so to allow or not allow the a the the
recreational markets to sell an
otherwise legal product would be a
policy Choice currently we don't the the
current law does not allow the atcs to
sell hemp derived CBD they are
prohibited from growing hemp and
extracting CBD from it uh that's that's
a policy consideration in order for them
to uh in order for them to be able to
sell um additional ratio products that
have higher percentages of CBD if the
question is leaning towards what do we
do about unregulated hemp derived THC
products then there's they're currently
prohibited by legislation
uh passed last year um and I know
there's a there's a model in some one of
these bills that would allow the Liquor
Commission to regulate hemp derived um
products
um which
is a solution to that is allowing the
cultivators under an adult use model to
cultivate
hemp and extract various cannaboids from
it growing hemp is cheaper you know than
growing cannabis the the idea is for
anyone selling CBD That Remains the Same
that's not going to be regulated by any
of this that's its own situation right
now there's a lot of stores selling that
they don't they're not going to require
license to sell that anyone
manufacturing purely CBD without the THC
we don't want we want that makes perfect
sense to me all right thank
you kale then Sean you next thank you Mr
chair so in in your suggestion here
you're looking for potency limits on
certain Recreational Products I I think
we all agree we we want to see some
potency limit limits on some of the
Recreational Products is there currently
potency limits on any of your
therapeutic products no there are not
and it's appropriate to not have those
limits because High potency products and
high milligram per serving products are
essential for certain patients to
achieve appropriate symptom
relief so no there are no potency limits
or serving size limits on therapeutic
products Mr
represent uh I I would add there yes
there are limits on the amount of
cannabis that can be obtained by
patients uh in a in a 10day period and
that is 2 ounces every 10
days
uh you you partially answered this
question but if I if an individual has a
therapeutic card and walks into a say
hybrid hypothetical hybrid facility that
has both medical and
recreational what incentivizes that
person holding that card to go to the uh
the medical versus recreational and what
could we put into a statute that would
encourage those individuals to continue
on with the medical program versus the
recreational the number one reason is
price Recreation uh therapeutic products
are traditionally in other Mar markets
significantly less because they are not
taxed um so that that is that is the
model that that uh operates in other
states the other incentives are I am not
I'm not buying I don't have product
availability on the rec side to get the
10 to1 CBD THC ratio products um and I'm
certainly not going to get get a
suppository over there on the rec side
I'm going to have to go into the uh onto
the the the the adult the uh the
therapeutic
counter represent kale thank you Mr
chair this is directed at the board um
if there was a dual combining of these I
think we would we would need to um put
in a statute that in order to get the
high potency things they would still
have to have the
card you know like if we do write that
in so just to clarify like the potential
is if you have the cannabis card you may
be allowed to purchase other products
that perhaps someone without the card
wouldn't be able to purchase and that
could actually apply to any store
technically cannot have two different
you know agencies doing rule making you
got to pick one or the other 18 TCS want
to you know come join the the franchise
Model come on in but if they don't if
there's a rationale which they have
convinced me totally convinced me that
they should stay just the way they are
they have a plenty of perks here like
they don't have limits that's a good
thing right for them they have they
aren't taxed they aren't you there's
plenty of reasons why the atc's can be
thriving and continue to do and take
care of those New Hampshire customers um
and I I think that Just the Two Worlds
should never should come never come
together and nothing's preventing
someone who has an interest in
ATC from perhaps trying to acquire a
franchise as well correct and I think if
I understood that testimony from last
last time we were here that person would
have a significant amount of experience
in the industry so when it comes to the
criteria you would consider for granting
the franchise well that's that's
obviously a huge plus so they not not
that they they have per se an advantage
but this having experience in the
industry will give them a you can't have
two desks two windows you can't have and
this is this is regulated by Health and
Human Services this is regulated by the
commission no that's that's it's insane
you can't do other states have
successfully adopted that model and
allowed um you know the medical Market
to uh uh to to be maintained and to and
to thrive I used to I did Ru making for
the Department for you know almost 15
years and you know
there there are plenty of examples where
there is dual regulatory Authority and
shared rulemaking responsibility
requirements um you know statutory
language including you know there's a
prim uh shall consult with uh prior to
uh rulem you know simply sets up a
requirement for um collaboration between
agencies statutorily that's something
that we you know is is is is not common
but it's not unheard of um and can
easily be um easily be implemented
you have an example for that uh we have
we have joint rul making Authority with
the Lottery Commission um for something
um we have uh uh we have it in food the
milk board um milk sanitation board um
there's there's there's
joint we I personally wouldn't recommend
joint rulemaking because I agree that
that is a cumbersome process um but in
consultation with built into the statute
requires collaboration ation um at a
higher level than simply the other
agency being a a stakeholder that can
come to a public rul making hearing I
would I would encourage that kind of uh
language I I I have no problems with two
departments like you said that if if the
if the lior commission comes up with
testing regulations that there's nothing
stopping Health and Human Services to
have a hearings and change their
whatever their rule is to to mirror that
one there's no nothing stopping them
from mirroring each other if they if
they say the other one's got a good idea
of how to do that that would certainly
make the rules process faster and easier
if they can have the two of them but I
agree full wholeheartedly and I think
one of the things that I think Mike's
suggestion sometimes that in
consultation just allows us in
perpetuity depending you know we don't
have to worry about the personalities of
who's in charge at that particular
moment to make sure that it's baked in
that at least there'll be a
collaborative atmosphere when you make
those rules it's just a
consideration thank you Mr chair you may
be surprised rep representative hunt but
I fully agree with you on that point I I
think one single state system is
probably the cleanest way to go I do
have a question and this is this would
be I think one distinction between the
the franchise model and the ATC model
currently you're selling um products at
99% THC which is shattered dabs and oils
so can you do you have any data on on
basically the um the amount in on an
annual level that is going out at that
extremely high potency
level with your sales we don't we uh no
I do not have data on the specific
amount of um Rel the the the sales
volume of certain products the atcs
certainly do um and and we but we could
certainly uh get that information um uh
for you the atcs would be happy to
provide it too okay okay followup it
seems to me that if this the franchise
model I would hope we're not going to be
selling products at that um intensity
level um that if if you do continue
forward that would be a little n niche
market market for you um certainly to be
purveying the the supersized um
product so there you go do Dr Younger
yeah so and for the commission as as
well as you I I am just trying to figure
out so is what would keep like Granite
Le cannabis for example from applying
for a franchise if and I I definitely
understand what representative hun is
saying it's like there's there seems
like some conflict if they're like
literally in the same space but if
Granite Leaf cannabis had applied and
had a franchise in X you know X area and
across the street had a medical cannabis
I mean is there some reason why that
couldn't
happen no no I would invite I would
invite you to ask that question to to
the to Granite leavea
cannabis and I think from our
consideration is you know what we would
do in that crosswalk is not create
unnecessary barriers I I keep pointing
to the testing because that's probably
the most tangible that you would want to
at least have similar standards so you
don't it's not completely apples and
oranges so Trish I just want to make
sure I'm clear on this so my concern was
the not for-profit status of a uh and
how it enters into the retail market and
where there might be conflict where in
regular you have you may have regulation
in in the Cannabis Market that doesn't
allow that or in medical Market that
doesn't allow that so that was my
concern is making sure again where they
cross like I don't necessarily think
having ATC or dispensary having a retail
license is a bad idea if they use that
to supplement keeping Medical Market
lower U the fact that the medical
Market's not going to be charged a taxes
the retail Market will um but there's a
possibility of allowing them to keep the
more robust Medical Market alive um if
you will um but my my concern was your
regulatory requirements on the medical
market and whether or not you have
prohibitions that would be in Conflict
so we currently do we currently require
the not for-profit status I think that's
a place where again when we have a solid
bill that we can look at we can point to
and say that's a place that you could
consider making changes in
126k um or X I'm sorry 126x um as a
department I we
are you know we are fairly agnostic on
the non-for-profit not for-profit we
want to make sure that they align you
know at the end of the day I want to
make sure it's affordable I want to make
sure it's safe I want to make sure it's
accessible if we can advance those ideas
that's that's what we're interested
in the other thing I would just add to
that as well I think historically I I
just want to acknowledge the historic
piece of the not for-profit sense is
that it is my understanding that at the
time many years ago while we were doing
this there was this notion around big
cannabis coming in I don't know it there
is certainly some uh thoughts that have
changed in that um as of today but I
want to acknowledge that that was the
concern many years ago as therapeutic
cannabis came on board and why I believe
it landed on the not for-profit status
was that it was not going to be a
commercialized big cannabis industry
whatever that means the current right
right now there's only one other state
there's only one other state um that
requires um their medical programs to be
not for-profit every other state that
had a nonprofit requirement has removed
it um uh identifying that as a barrier
for the um the medical program to enter
the the retail Market um having two
different business models under the same
entity is a unnecessary barrier it was
found Arizona is the only state that
still requires nonprofit status um and
the other point is that it is not it is
not believed that nonprofit status
reduces the price of product it is it is
a certainty that the nonprofit status
actually increases the price of product
and I invite the you to ask the atc's uh
that question on how the requirement for
the atcs to be a nonprofit impacts their
business model in terms of investment
debt payment Etc yeah obviously they can
speak to that much more elegantly than
we
can yeah sorry I'd like to follow up on
Miss Nero's uh question line of
questioning just for a moment really
quickly uh is it is it true that uh you
uh identified the fact that there is no
uh THC percentage concentration of Delta
9 THC limit on any of the products sold
in the atcs is that correct that is
correct okay and are you aware of the uh
scientific studies that associate High
concentration uh THC uh consumption with
cannabis use disorder uh yes we are we
have we work closely with our medical
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board uh and and that's an issue that uh
they've explored and and taken up we're
we're aware of the uh the the existence
and the prevalence of cannabis use
disorder in certain segments of the
population especially with with regard
to heavy chronic use and once a card is
issued uh and if there's no limit on the
concentration um how does that medical
board or cons
consults um monitor a patient uh who
doesn't have to see a practitioner
thereafter uh to identify whether or not
that individual who's been purchasing
high concentration TC has developed
cannabis use
disorder Dr Younger answer yeah so um
you know every every practice is
different but like for example at
Dartmouth we have our patients come and
at least every 3 to six months um with
like set functional goals we were
testing during that time with some
validated testing for cannabis use
disorder including like you had
mentioned like how often in the last
week have you felt high things like that
so um I I think that they don't require
that that happens but I think most uh
good practitioners are do have some
follow-up plan when they're certifying
someone for cannabis um and the patient
at least in our institution are required
to come before they are recertified we
have to complete that paperwork you know
once every one to three years the time
and the person could then potentially go
to another provider because there's no
um well let me ask a foundational
question then um for therapeutic
cannabis it is not part of the um
prescription monitoring program pdmp
correct so the is not but it would be
great if it was well perhaps that should
be a requirement but um so effectively
then the patient could just go doctor
shop from practitioner to practitioner
every time they need a new card correct
okay and and one last follow that was
that was a bill that passed well well
pass in the house at beding 2019 2020
that pass in the house I believe in the
pdmp we got we got to move to we have
one more
question thank you Mr chair I have uh
a I have a question regarding the cost
factor and the structure of the state
system as we're approaching it is to
keep costs as low as possible and so we
have uh that's the direction we're
moving in so that we can undercut other
undercut other states and are you
concerned that this is a um a patient
was uh I was speaking to just recently
said that they they couldn't afford uh
the ATC pricing structure well hence the
the need for a black market correct so I
mean this is something that is of
concern to you and and for us to
understand this it is believed that if
the atcs can enter the adult youth Mar
market and make um the majority of their
uh their operating costs from uh retail
use that uh therapeutic uh product
prices will come down okay okay thank
you but again that would be a better
question for the
atc's I just have
a it's not curio so somebody has a
medical to get from a doctor so they can
the different dispensar can feasable
somebody could go to one get that two o
and then go to the other and get two
ounces or is it some sort of
coordination where
they we we uh it's a good question we
enforce those limits
um while while it's while it's while
it's feas while it's feasibly possible
um uh the department has a process by
which we monitor um uh sales across all
the atc's um and uh and uh send you know
we've started we've sent warning letters
don't do it again and that compliance
has uh has come down significantly um
since the uh the law allowed uh all the
patients to go to all the atcs so where
technically um they don't have yes right
right now they don't have a shared
system um uh data system for the
transaction history between the the
multiple entities uh we have a um an
enforcement side of our program that
enforces that and we have the authority
under statute to uh revoke cards based
on that uh that
violation thank thank you for your time
I see any more questions anyone have
seeing No Hands raised I want to thank
both both the witnesses from bhhs for
the time thank you thank
you so we're not gonna we're probably
not going to make it through 1598 today
just I know everyone's uh
shock was really anticipating that that
uh enlightening process but anyway we
have another draft too so that will be
handed out to members of the commission
we'll we'll go over that it's another
draft that's kind of floating around so
we'll cover that but before I know some
people may have to be taken off we
should set the next meeting date now Mr
chair if I may I'd like to propose a
couple dates to try to get an extension
so people can plan their schedule and
and some proposed topics for those dates
you don't mind you're more than welcome
but start with the dates all right so
I'm going to stick with
Thursdays and so
10:19 and my recommendation for that
meeting is we ask C AG to come in to
answer questions we have about legality
issues and and have that conversation
and whatever time is left over from that
to allow for public comment do you think
it's just and I'll welcome anyone to
comment on this should we go over the
draft that we have before so we can kind
of gather the concerns we have with the
policy and then maybe we vet vetted
thereafter
U Mr chair I think that what was
discussed in in the first meeting uh and
I don't mean to speak for
um uh Mr Mara Esquire that uh the
proposal was to hear from uh the various
uh department and commission and agency
heads first perhaps some subject matter
experts and then uh with that armed with
that information much like we have heard
from Liquor Commission DHHS who may
actually be required to come back with
some additional information we just that
was that was the goal we have a draft
and asked about how to implement it you
know the ATC policies into that and how
they would be integrated I understand
what the what the handout says but I'm
talking about the actual legislation
they didn't want to do that until we had
a product to present to them so
shouldn't we have a product present
that's the final product and people see
a draft and
they I keep thinking that people want to
I think for the interest people that are
interested in this they need to see a
proposal and then they can pick apart
the proposal well with all due respect I
don't I I think that's a bit of an
exercise of putting the cart for the
horse in that uh these uh department
heads Commissioners uh in subject matter
exports would help us craft a better
legislation then rather than looking at
it first listening to them and then
having to go back and do it again so Mr
chair if I can go finish go through this
and then might answer some of these
questions right again so I tend to agree
with the chief I think having the AG in
to answer some questions may help us
craft better legislation uh going
forward and help Define that so again my
my recommendation was to have the AG
come in on the 19th um and answer
questions have a conversation of his
understanding of um commissioner Malik's
uh proposal for a franchise
understanding dhs's now they have a
basis us to understand where we're kind
of heading and he can comment on that
help us craft legislation so on the 19th
we would have the AG in and then anytime
that's left over allow for public
comment does the 19th work
for raise your hand if it
works ra your hand it
works is there a time on Dr uh young is
there a time on the 19th that's
better
so 10 a.m. n or n either
one is there is there another date that
might work well we're GNA have a bunch
of dates so I'm trying to get get
through and get all the dates down so we
can yeah that's what I'm thinking I was
going to try and get through the whole
list and then we can talk about so the
we'll have one hearing on the 19th we'll
we'll start it can we I'm I'm totally
unavailable a on the 19th I saw some
other people had their hand didn't raise
their hands as well that aren't
available so how many people
unavailable does the 18
work four of
us
18 I'm
you could so anyone who's available in
the 18th raise your
hand
okay 19th 19th it is 19th and we'll do
9:30 instead of instead so Mr chair
going through the next date
112 I I can't do the second what's that
I'm not available on the second okay
what date would you
propose
I was just trying to stick with Thursday
so every could plan accordingly but we
need to jump around days that's fine we
do something next week maybe instead of
I mean we don't have to do it every
other week can we 19's next week that
next week no that's week after that's
the week after why can we do something
next week 12 yeah like the 12th instead
of the 19th for the 11th or the 10th or
the 9th or the 13th I I can't do the
12th I can't either I other commit it's
a short it's a short week what about
like the 10th 11th 12th 13th like
there's four days
there let let me run through let me run
through all the dates I proposed and
then we can start banging them around
because I think we have enough time
everything we're doing I'm I'm worried
about the December 1st date and making
sure we get to a solution by December
1st how about October 23rd is that date
raise your hand it's a Monday what do we
start the week raise your hand if you're
available on Monday the 23rd to replace
the 19th we I think we're g do both yes
I will not be
AV not
available the whole
week right I'll be in
amdam say I'm gonna try anything while
I'm there I'm sure you wouldn't but
research and just the live
streams what about the 26 19th and the
27 we're scheduled I think both the
house and uh Senate
going to be
concession would the 24th be better than
the 23rd I think not for represent the
hunt he'll be an
aning I'm being I'm away on the I fly
away on the 22nd suay the 22nd and I fly
back November 1 so November 2nd I was
available am available
so why don't we do the n why just do the
19th and 24th for now 19 and 24 okay so
on the 19th we'll have the AG and public
comment on the 24th we'll start with
public comment and go into work session
what about
atcs uh you want to bring atcs in I
sounds I think we should have them
after after the B so on the 24th we'll
plan the atcs and public
comment I I think it it'd be very
important before we get too far ahead uh
meeting with a lot of people this I I
spoke about this organization it's
called getting it right from the St
advancing public health and equity in
canvas policy the woman is uh Dr Lyn
silver she's an MD mph faap senior
adviser for the Public Health Institute
in in California and if you go to that
website I encourage everybody here to go
to that website uh she's they this
organization's evaluated what has worked
what hasn't worked and
suggests uh and suggest what should be
in legislation she's willing to come
here to speak from
California so again my my thought was
leaving it just a public comment allows
anybody who wants to sign up to testify
you can sign up to testify and give
public comment so if atcs want to come
in they can come in if the doctor wants
to come in the doctor can come in um
that was the idea of just leaving an
open comment period is allow anybody who
we may not be even thinking of rather
than try to figure out who everybody is
I would strongly recommend that this
woman not come in to to sign up as a
public speaker but we should have her
here to make a presentation I think it
would be very useful to us is there
anyone here from the atc's please raise
your
hand now is it the preference of the
atcs to have a
presented template or model from the
commission but then the atcs to comment
on and say what works what doesn't work
or is it just the preference to have us
put something together after the fact
once we receive your
recommendations it's
okay 24th we G have the atcs in public
comment 19th the 19th we add the AG I
think we're going to do you want to add
THC so we'll get rid of the public
comment and we'll add
AG then on then the 24th is just public
comment I think what we're going to do I
think we could do may I yes um I think
if we do if we get three dates on the
books 1019 Ag and public comment 1024
atc's and public comment and then
November 2nd this getting it right group
and maybe we could do a little public
comment I mean and then I'm not
available to okay so one more date to do
that and that's three dates of
presentations public comment and then we
can really start get in the work session
correct that was Mr chair so we just
need that third date yeah well we had
the second but what Mr chairman what
works for you that week of the
second Mr chair I have a question it
feels like um there's several other
entities that on the state level that
have um you know uh skin in the game
here the state treasurer the Chief Med
medical officer Commissioner of safety
Commissioner of Public Health um we
heard from public health not the
commissioner but we did hear from them
regarding appointed um conversation on
atc's um so there's other stakeholders
that we would like to hear hear from and
um they will be traveling in in addition
to the getting it right um from the
start that Mr Mara spoke to so can it
can we potentially have a a date if if
we leave the last two week uh two weeks
of November for example for work
sessions uh on 1598 is there any way we
could Target another date uh so that I
can speak to some of the medical
community that would like to come in and
speak they have they have uh pretty busy
schedule so it the more time we have
advanced notice the better just just I
don't have an issue with that but I'm
just going to emphasize whatever this
commission does around recommends or
doesn't recommend it's still going to be
public Hearing in the legislator both
the house and the Senate so there's
still a long way to go if if whatever
this commission does or does not
recommend that is not the the finished
product that's still going to go to the
Committees in the house and in the
Senate so there's still a long way to go
what we're what we're up against is and
I think what we're trying to do is come
up with basically is it a
feasible recommendation on a state
controlled model for candidat report now
obviously their their input would matter
but we don't even have a draft yet for
anyone to comment on I still think
having a draft is the way to go I
because otherwise everyone's kind of
just throwing stuff at us but half that
stuff might be into these the these
hearings been going on since I was inol
I I understand that however a study
commission is our our purpose is to take
testimony and that testimony would
inform our um decision making whether
whether it's you know refining uh you
know past legislation or or recommending
new legislation so I I I know we agreed
upon this on on on our first meeting
September 8th that we would give
advanced notice and I would appreciate
that if at all possible why don't we why
don't we cover that on we'll discuss
we'll continue that conversation on the
19th because I don't know I think we'll
get more dates on the 19th so Mr chair
if I go back the 11th on the week of 11
112 you said you're not available the
111 work that's a
Wednesday 111 is on the table well I'm
asking the chair he can't do the second
so what would work for him and then we
can 111
anyone how about this we have two dates
we'll worry about I think we
should I think we have two two's fine
that's my that's my it's a problem the
decision I we here we might as well thir
dat well we we have two but we're not
going to get too far ahead I think we
have the two I would especially if we're
going to invite I'm sorry Mr chair
especially if we're gonna invite someone
from California we might want to get
that third date on so they can do travel
plans and when we're here I feel like we
have some momentum to get that third
date on we have a pretty tight timeline
Mr chair to get this report out and so
I'm I'm feeling a little uh motivated to
get these things on the books as as
particularly as the fall gets even
busier and bus
year what would the topic for the third
meeting even be so again we have Ag and
public comment for 19 atcs we're going
to hear for the atcs and the AG in the
19th we got to give no they answer is
yes that's what we're going to do
oh public comment uh we can allow for
public comment thereafter but we want to
hear from both to get th get that
information because I think for us to
put a model together we got to hear from
both that means that draft won't even
really get going until after the 24th
the 24th would be I would propose public
comment again anybody can sign up we can
anybody can request an agency come in
during a public comment period just like
any public hearing um and we we can move
into work session at that point in
reviewing 159 so 19th is AG and atc's
and then 24th is only public comment
public comment and if there's time
remaining work session okay and then go
through 1598 or any proposal that we
might have we're going to scrap 1598
there a different proposal that kind
proposal and use a date the first week
of November to invite uh getting it
right I would Echo your concern that we
are working somewhat in a vacuum right
now without actually having a proposal
on the table we've now had four hours of
presentations from two agencies because
we are operating in a vacuum which has
turned into a freewheeling discussion
about the merits of
marijuana our purpose is to propose
legislation let's work the way that most
of committees do put proposed
legislation on the table allow for
comments on that the comment could be
this is terrible legislation you need to
start over but that stops us from
working the complete vacuum in which
we're taking two hours per
testimony I couldn't agree more well
said you said about 10 times better than
I was trying to say and there is a draft
that that's been put together here I'll
circulate that but that's not going to
be 1598 but I think for everyone to have
will let everyone take a look at that so
you're going to want to read that
obviously before um the 19th as well and
then I'll make sure that a copy that's
provided to the atc's um any members of
the atc's please email myself um or
anyone else in the committee requesting
that information so we can provide it in
advance so you have some time to review
it it's not uh obviously it's a
multi-page
document and and who who who made that
draft because I haven't seen any draft
and I know that there are members that
have wanted to suggest I just would like
a little more structure to whatever
draft is going to be circula
for example I know that you know the
public health folks are getting together
to work on suggestion so before that
draft goes up for example I would like
this information to be included in that
draft yeah I haven't I haven't read this
to see if it's so that's why I'm saying
I want to wait before a draft goes out
before to have enough in there yeah and
again this is the the first draft I'm
sure there'll be a lot of edits to it so
if that's not in there it most certainly
welcome in there I accept to I I want to
uh kudos to new futures for doing what
we at ask which is be specific about
what language you would like to see in
it so I urge people to have opinions
about what they think should be in the
bill to do what new Futures do and that
applies for virtually any type of
hearing Bill legislation not just
cannabis thank
you any any other comment
on
choose that third dat the first week of
November Mr chair I just want to clarify
that that um October 24th is going to be
exclusive public comment open open
comment correct is that am I
understanding that correctly if we bring
the atcs in
on 19 24th the idea was public comment
meaning anybody can sign up the testify
and provide information and and then if
there's any time left over we can move
into some sort of work session great
thank
you would the 20 would the 24th be a
great good for the person from
California coming
in I think we can that's that's enough
I've noticed to bring
in across country sure would the 24th
work for the person coming from
California
I think I think our deadline would be
December 1st so it would be too
late Mr share is there are we not
allowed to use people or to use zoom or
whatever to get people to talk to us
like it seems there's there are a lot of
experts in this country the idea of
having to fly people in is our only way
to talk to them seems maybe not
realistic in this exact scenario what
you're saying makes sense the as you
open the door you have doctors from
every state call in which what they'll
be allowed to do once once you open the
floor like that so I I don't believe
someone would be able to participate
provide testimony remote they could
provide a PowerPoint or uh written
testimony I mean they can even send us a
you know they can make their YouTube
video and send it to the committee I
mean they can do what they can send us
information but if the just let us know
if that works um we have so we can set
the agenda in
advance Mr chair throw some dates out so
we have without topics we have at least
have dates that
we I I would like I would like to say
that we've started a trend Thursday
mornings let's just say commit that
we're going to do Thursday mornings from
now on now we know not everyone's going
to be able to do it but at least this
means that everybody knows that that
November they know that it's Thursday
morning so the next Thursday I'm able to
do is is the 9th the nth the 16 so 28th
for the final
meeting I can be here the second if you
would like me to share
something or your
clerk up but I'm just saying it's it's
that we've traded a when schedule mine I
seeway I know I I appreciate that we'll
put the ninth as the as the other as
next dat after that we could do we could
do Friday the 3D I understand we have
the Precedence of Thursdays but nothing
stopping us from using any other day uh
we could do that Friday the 3D and then
from then on out be be Thursday mornings
and that way everybody knows now that
for the rest of the month we're gonna
we're going to reserve Friday the 3D and
November 9th if we want just please
check the calendar one of those may get
cancelled and then we have the
16th and then I moved it back because of
we skip a week because of than
Thanksgiving and we go to the 29th which
should be our we'd have to have our
final product ready written and voted on
on the 28th rather I'm sorry Tuesday
that gives us a couple days in case we
have to hurry up and schedule something
else before the first
deadline will they all be at 9:00 am you
thinking 9 or 10 a. uh we're doing we're
only doing uh the 19th at 9:30 I think
it was the
accomodate the dark
everything else will be
attend we again
1924 of October 113 which is a Friday
move 119 11:16 and 1128 are all the
dates people can put in their calendar
just hold them and we'll figure out what
the topics are on all of
them very helpful M Mr chair quick
question if we have to get a substitute
for ourselves because we're at another
meeting is that is that something we
do I don't believe you need a substitute
uh if someone's running late just keep a
surprise you know as you can tell he G
on for a
while yeah
know the 28th would be a voting day and
you would have to be present to vote on
the final report so so we're meeting on
the 20th works so I have a zoom hearing
that I have to the 20th for me is a
tight
date so I might have to we to do 27th
you want to do the 27th do the 27th it's
a
Monday yeah 27th inste of 28th why we's
got Zoom I have to be I have a I teach
on Mondays what
time in the
morning you could do 9 on the 27 so
we'll do 9 o00 we're going to do 9 o' on
the
27th as well 28 or and you you'll all
get the dates we'll we'll send out a
notice and everyone will get here's what
was in the minutes and here's the dates
and times so we at least know the dates
and times R when schedule and then we'll
worry about topics as we get get
there say those dates one more time make
sure I got it right 11:19 at
930 9:30 um
10:24
10 yeah 10 109 1019
11:24 say 11 104 10 sorry in front of me
all right this one we're going to go one
at a time I'm just going to name it off
what I wrote down so we have October
19th at 9:30
a then we have October
24th at 10
a.m. we have November
3rd at 10 a.m. we have November 9th at
10: a.m. we have November 16th at 10:
a.m. and then we have the
27th of November at 9:00
am. you we'll send that an
email he wasn't here for
the okay move to adjourn
good all right move to a
jour